soirée bienvenue comme tous les soirs
dans touche pas à mon
wow quel bonheur de vous retrouver tous
les soirs bienvenue vous êtes bien sûr
des 8 oui 10 8
vous êtes sûr des 8 entouré de mes amis
de mes camarades les amours de mais
bosser merci bonsoir valérie bénaïm est
avec nous
dans la vie comment va la vie humble
avis elle va magnifique jeu les
week-ends jeudi week-end formidable la
toge bat toujours un petit cadeau un
petit week-end un petit bouquet non j'ai
eu un petit bracelet il n'a pas osé
encore le un petit bracelet quoi un gros
reims merci beaucoup mais
il est avec nous tous les soirs il
s'appelle jean michel maire et toute
importance voilà week end agité
j'étais nantes très calme parce que
j'avais ma fille mais ce week-end je
compte me rattraper une grosse soirée au
queen années 80 j'ai sorti mon habit de
lumière et je vais envoyer du mois
j'aimerais bien elle est vraiment
j'aimerais bien là avec vous je vous
invite
c'est tout il y'a pas toi
non mais c'est
c'est pas parce que si vous voulez comme
tous les soirs je les présente et que ça
commence à devenir une routine pour moi
c'est un peu spécial c'est bien isabelle
vous êtes là et
isabelle morini bosc
à chaque fois j'ai envie de vous appeler
dubosc alors qu' aucun rapport mais moi
je veux bien que j'aime bien franck donc
donc ça va mais moi ça me tombe va tous
vous l'avez vu ce week-end franck dubosc
oui j'ai juste vu mon mari on avait une
dispute à finir vous avez commencé une
dispute
vous aviez commencé une dispute et vous
deviez la terminer ça s'est terminé
comme en août toujours à ben moi il m'a
pour faire masqué si sûr et qu'est ce
qu'il a pourquoi vous êtes disputer on
m'a alors vous savez vinon d'années que
je cumule au compteur on sera même plus
besoin de prétextes vous savez même pas
pourquoi vous dites parfois vous êtes en
train de s'engueuler il me semble déjà
ça s'entretient
on s'entretient en tout cas moi je
n'embrasse votre mari parce que
franchement il a du mérite
intellectuel l'homme de cinéma
l'homme aux cheveux monsieur christophe
carrière cava christophe y en a très
bien défendu
détendez vous avez été voir des films
non je suis allé à marseille ce week-end
sur les traces de tournage à marseille
sur les traces de tournage d'un parent a
french et tout ce qui va sortir le
tournoi avec jean dujardin et gilles
lellouche à la fda french premier film
sur la manucure 1
mais on va aller voir ce film en tout
cas c'est formidable c'est bien mais
c'est vous le dites je pense que on voit
du bois la west et des brèches mon bien
ouais celui père bien bas pour que
j'aille à marseille deux jours en
immersion pour voir où ils ont tourné
quand même manseng ces créneaux maison
pénalisent investi en immersion de la
diact et ben non non non bah ouais non
parce que j'étais avec des tour
opérators mais des vrais marseillais
quoi tu menais ça s'est tournée quoi
voilà d'ailleurs je les salue s'étaient
tous fait assez fort parce que de
prendre le tgv je fais pas mal
franchement ces efforts j'ai merdé hélas
tous les soirs et là c'est un bonheur de
vous retrouver quatre mois à venir
partager vraiment vraiment comment va
pas tous très bien ouais aller à travers
embrasserait pour moi avec plaisir c'est
vrai ouais vous avez fait quoi vous ce
week end
je suis en train de lui trouver un
cadeau là deux visions
le hockey est bon pour le bol pour le
patin je n'avais pas dit le pigeon pour
le bracelet quoi est ce que le mien il
est pas ces règles ne sont pas d'accord
voilà jean yves lemoine est avec nous je
souris
joy cook donc jean luc lemoine c'est
vrai que j'ai dit jean-yves parce que à
chaque fois tous les soirs de dire jean
yves vous avez envie de changer
moi j'ai envie de changer voilà mais
c'est bien normal merci beaucoup robert
gelli genre ils ont peu près à ce moment
et on mettra jean-luc ouais ça va jean
luc boussard va très bien vous faites
quoi en ce moment bon en ce moment je
prépare mon nouveau spectacle et puis le
reste du temps je profite du fait que j
le cherche un cadeau pour fatou pour
être avec fatou jean-luc je suis
vraiment désolé d'avoir fait cette
erreur sur le prénom bref j'ai vécu
tellement de charcuterie de nom et de
prénom de la part des gens m'appelaient
gadel longtemps disait au téléphone je
peux parler intel on me disait c'est
qu'ils et gad elmaleh le gars disaient
c'est gadel donc et donc spectacle tout
seul sur scène non je vais avoir pris à
partie gad elmaleh justement en tout cas
j'ai un grand respect pour votre métier
faire rire les gens seuls sur scène
c'est pas évident non c'est un travail
de tous les jours mais
essayez un jour
jean yves lemoigne
3 janvier
laura ma la grèce
elora je vous ai gardé pour la fin
aujourd'hui j'ai présenté tout le monde
et les amis ça d'habitude je ne fais
jamais ça
oui mais c'est la première fois je vous
ai mis en cerise en chantilly en cherry
on the cake en 2010 dans topping de
sunday merci et comment vous le vivez
mais je gère j'adore j'ai l'impression
des petits éclats de noix comme ça ça me
fait plaisir parce avait très très bien
votre conversation
merci jean yves eux écoutez on va parler
bien entendu comme tous les soirs de
tout ce qui s'est passé à la télé tous
on l'a vu tout ce qu'on a défi dénicher
de ce qu'on a décidé chine et ses
papiers chine essaie d'enlever un truc
qui étaient chinois à la base mais voilà